we've had the latest coronavirus figures  for the united kingdom  let's tell you what they are 35 928 new  cases of covid 19 in today's figures  that's a pretty big jump from 27  000 yesterday so a nearly 9 000.  new cases as compared to yesterday in  terms of deaths  again sadly 326 deaths within 28 days of  a positive test have been announced  today  and just going back to cases  particularly instructive when you  compare it on the week by week averages  so  in the last seven days there's been a  51.2  rise in the number of cases in  comparison to the previous seven days  earlier in december so  a really sharp rising cases in the uk  and yet again sadly more deaths 326  reported today